I've got my own problems to worry about.
Those people in Africa don't wanna help themselves.
It's their mess, why should I care?
Their problems are too big to solve.
Stop wasting my hard-earned money.
Hey, I'm as compassionate as the next guy.
But it's like throwing money down a rat hole.
Nothing will ever change.
I give up.
What's the point?
Where's the proof?
Actually, SMART programs are saving lives.
In just ten years, over 15 million more kids are alive.
And over 46 million more kids are in school.
All for less than one percent.
One percent. One percent of the total US budget.
How's that for proof?
And today, there are new vaccines that can save millions of more kids.
But it won't happen without you.
Go to one.org and join the movement.
Add your voice to over two million ONE members around the world.
We're not asking for your money. We're asking for your voice.